get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel helps make our show possible and
it's an app I actually use myself to
improve my Italian and it's definitely
the first language learning app I'd
recommend to anyone
go check it out this next story is so
insane that it is almost unbelievable
and difficult to even explain but I'm
going to try Donald Trump concocted a
plan to ambush the parents of a grieving
child with the woman who killed their
child in a traffic accident last week I
told you the story about the wife of an
American diplomat her name is Ann
cyclist she was in the United Kingdom
with her husband her husband was
stationed there she ran over and killed
a British teenager 19 year old named
Harry Dunne who was riding a motorcycle
because she rode she drove on the wrong
side of the street Donald Trump had a
very strange reaction last week where we
discussed it where Trump said it happens
and he said I won't say it hasn't
happened to me I guess referring to
driving on the wrong side of the road in
England I don't really know what he
meant I also didn't think Donald Trump
drove but in any case it's open to
interpretation what Trump meant by that
but the parents of the deceased 19 year
old have been lobbying Donald Trump to
send an cyclists back to the United
Kingdom to face justice now we don't
know if what she did would have her
criminally liable a responsible jail
time we don't know anything about that
what we do know is she fled the United
Kingdom when this all went down claiming
questionable diplomatic immunity because
her husband was not actually registered
as a diplomat according to at least one
lawyer so the Dunn family comes to the
United States not necessarily expecting
to meet with Trump based on the reports
I've seen but suddenly they receive an
invitation from the White House marked
urgent to come and visit with Donald
Trump in the White House on Tuesday
night less than 48 hours ago and Donald
Trump has since admitted that he
actually sprung on the family that hey
the killer
and so coulis is right over in the next
room over how about I bring her in
here's Donald Trump explaining it in the
bizarre way that only Donald
can once again talking about it happens
and it also sounds like Trump thinks
they drive on the left side of the road
in all of Europe which is of course not
true but a minor detail just another one
of the many details Trump doesn't
understand meeting with the family was
really it was beautiful in a certain way
they did not want to meet with the
person in question but we had a very
good meeting they're very nice people it
was very sad to be honest he lost and
they lost their son I believe it was
going down the wrong way because that
happens in Europe you go to Europe and
the roads are opposite and it's very
tough if you're from the United States
you do make that that decision to make a
right turn were you supposed to make a
left turn the roads are out the city and
she said that's what happened that
happens to a lot of people by the way
but she said that's what happened she
was in the room right out there we met
right here and these this area and I
offered to bring the person in question
and and they weren't ready for it but I
did offer I spoke with Boris he asked me
if I do that and I did it of course the
parents were instantly traumatized by
this incredibly crass and short-sighted
and totally ignorant idea they said no
we don't want to meet the person who ran
over and killed our son and Trump has
since acknowledged that the parents
weren't ready to meet the woman who ran
over and killed their son and now as
they see it is evading justice but
happened to be sitting in the next room
over Donald Trump had the idea almost
like he's a game show host which is
actually a term we've used before to
describe his presidency that he'd
convinced the parents that this is a
good idea to have this meeting and that
then he would sweep in and cyclists from
the next room over in front of a spray
of photographers and it would be some
kind of a media event of some sort I
have a surprise for you behind door
number three can you guess who it is
can you guess something very very wrong
with this man and there's actually
something even more stunning the parents
say Harry Dunn's parents say that up
until the moment when Donald Trump tried
to spring the
Killer on them from the next room over
that they were actually impressed with
Trump they said that Trump was
comforting that Trump was responding
well to their grief which is something
we have never seen Donald Trump do or be
in the face of tragedies usually Donald
Trump is the opposite of empathetic and
comforting remember going to Puerto Rico
after the hurricane and shooting paper
towels like basketballs as if it's some
kind of game the entire spectacle is
completely cruel and ill-considered and
then to add to this apparently at some
point either before or after their
meeting with Trump the Robert O'Brien
the u.s. national security advisor told
the family that Ansah coulis is never
going back to the United Kingdom to face
justice on top of all of this this is
the Jerry Springer is a ssin of the
presidency with the exception that Jerry
Springer actually showed some compassion
and empathy for the people on his
program a headline that you have to
really look at closely to realize that
it's not satirical news but it is the
reality of the world in Trump 2019 the
era in which we now find ourselves